bitcoin is ripping forty two thousand
eight hundred dollars literally went up
500 bucks since we went to commercial
i don't want to say that we did that but
i do want to say
that will clemente is here and maybe
that's what's going on let's bring will
up
when i when i went when we went to
commercial i got on the zoom and i said
well you good and
his exact response to me was damn y'all
lit
what's up man boys are going crazy this
morning what's going on man
how are you i'm doing well doing well
uh especially after watching this this
price chart here the last 5-10 minutes
all right let's start first with uh the
on-chain metrics for the week
uh i know that you've done a bunch of
the analysis as usual
and you're starting out with this urpd
metric
uh which is basically on chain volume
explain what you're seeing
yeah so urpd is basically um like if you
think of a volume profile it's usually
used like if you're in tradingview or
something on the side of the screen
it's basically just a horizontal um
uh volume distribution metric and so
showing you like
how much bitcoin has moved at different
price levels and so when we look at this
we have this
massive zone of volume obviously we've
been in this range for like
two three months now um we've had almost
22 percent
21.7 percent of uh supply has moved in
this range
and then we have this massive bar of
volume at about 39.5 and
2.6 percent of bitcoin's money supply
moved at that bar which makes it
the largest singles down like single bar
of um
of distribution at that price level
since 3.8
000 so you know we're building up this
huge
what i believe is kind of this mid-cycle
support possibly
you know if we had another macro bear
market perhaps some kind of like macro
bear market uh
bottom level that we're forming here
because we have so much uh
volume especially at that 39.5 level got
it
and then you created this top bottom uh
model what's going on with the uh top
model bottom
yeah so um there's a there's a lot here
but just to like
kind of break it down the easy way to
understand um the top model is a variant
it's basically a multiplier of
the average cap of bitcoin so like the
all-time moving average of bitcoin
um the light green line that you'll see
the second one to the bottom that's
realized cap
so that's the well realized price is
just you're dividing the cap by
circulating supply um but this is the
average price that investors paid for
their coins and then the very bottom
line
uh the dark green one is delta price um
so
delta cap is the difference between that
the all-time average uh the all-time
moving average cap
and realize cap so you can you know
plotting that out you can get almost
this like cheat sheet for looking at
um kind of these over underheated zones
uh
you know bitcoin has always historically
stayed between the the delta price and
the top model
um but then also adding in like the
realized price you can get a good zone
to accumulate you know at the at the
bare bottom
and then also um you can get some some
good zones to
you know start start de-risking towards
the top of the cycle
but then i put this mid-line which is
basically the mean between
the delta price and the top price and so
this is kind of like
served as a good like confirmation level
for for
bull markets in the past um it was the
level obviously like
2013 got back above it but then broke
below this and
and that kind of led us into the bear
market in 2017 we rejected off of it and
then once we kind of broke back through
that retested it as support
um that kind of gave us the next leg up
um it was also where
we bounced off on the dead cat bounce so
like after we had that initial
euphoric run up then we had that that
second um
what people call dead cat bounce so it's
a higher low i mean it's a
it's a lower high um so basically a
bearish retest
and that bounced off that midline as
well and then this year we kind of
bounced off it as support
in in january and then um we broke
through that in
mid-may and that was kind of like the
mark where we kind of just dropped off a
cliff after we broke through that level
so
right now it's at 53k and that's that's
something i'll be looking for for
like full confirmation that we are you
know a new bullish uptrend
okay and then talk to us about this
illiquid supply shock ratio
i know that we've been talking this now
for two or three weeks kind of this idea
of a supply squeeze what's going on
there
yeah absolutely um this is something
i've been excited to finally see get
played out because i was pushing it so
hard but uh
there's two ways to look at this so you
have a
a more qualitative view of this and then
also more quantitative
so the liquid supply shock is the more
uh qualitative
so it's looking at what what's the uh
spending behavior of the entities that
these coins are moving to
um and so what you see and this is the
blue line uh
this is showing you that more coins are
moving to
what's unchained considered these strong
hands these these are liquid entities
and then also you see the purple line um
that's more of a
a quantitative way to look at the supply
shock so it's literally saying
um what's the ratio between the amount
of coins that are available to be bought
on exchanges relative to
the overall circulating supply and you
see you know if you overlay them both i
mean they
move pretty much in unison um but yeah
you're seeing divergences in both of
those that i don't think have
fully gotten uh priced yet you know
because these are divergences that have
been growing for
two three months and then really rapidly
over the last two three weeks and
and i really i think uh price is lagging
big time here
got it and then when we look at who's
actually buying i know that there's a
ton of
um kind of supply held by retail it
looks like
yeah so like breaking the breaking the
accumulation down by like who exactly is
accumulating in terms of size
what you see is that like all across the
board every major cohort is accumulating
aside from like the i think the 100 to
1000 cohort which is kind of just
trending sideways
um but what you see is retail has really
stuck out over the last well actually
since
since the march i mean the the make
capitulation but especially over the
last few weeks
their holdings have kind of hockey
sticked upwards um and
like the way i i looked at this in the
newsletter was comparing
all of these end of these holdings with
less than 10 bitcoins
and then dividing that by the
circulating supply so you get basically
the portion of supply
that retail holds that makes sense um
and you've seen that that's really gone
on its hair since since may 19th so
um you know retail although people like
to talk about how oh it's all way at
whales move the market retail's been
holding their own retail has really been
a driver of
of this uh reabsorption process that
we've been tracking
got it and then when you start thinking
about within that the short-term
uh holders and the long-term holders
this seems to be like uh
one of if not the most important charts
uh just showing that the long-term
holders are accumulating
yeah so this is comparing so like in the
past we've looked at
the the raw short-term and long-term
holdings
but this is comparing their holdings to
the overall supply so you're just
getting the portion of supply that each
of them holds so very similar to what we
just did with retail holdings
um and so what you see is like
historically whenever bitcoin starts
moving up it gets to a certain level of
holdings that of from long-term holders
because
of course they're locking up supply so
it's very similar um to the supply shock
thing
it's kind of a more abstract way to look
at it but right now we're at about 66
percent of supply held by long-term
holders whereas
like kind of in uh mid-october of last
year when we started really running up
into the main bowl phase
we got up to about 68 percent um
so yeah that's just something i would be
keeping an eye on like or are these
long-term holders going to continue to
add or
are they just going to dump on on any
sign of exit liquidity right like if we
start going up to whatever 45k
all of a sudden you know long-term
holders are just dumping like
that that's not going to be a good sign
because that kind of resembles what
happened in the dead cat bounce after
the 2013 fall
for sure and then dormancy what's that
looking like right now
yeah so dormancy is basically looking at
um the amount of
destruction so but it's adjusting it for
volume so like
destruction is is an on-chain term
looking at so like if you have a coin
and a wallet for one day
it has one coin day and then if it's
moved out of that wallet it's now got
one coin day destroyed
um and so then then dormancy adjusts
this for volume so you get the raw
you take the time component out of it
and then you only are looking at the raw
amount of destruction
um and so like plotting that out over
time um
you can basically see you know like or
or older
or older coins being sold um
but what david did david well um he took
the
the annualized uh dormancy in dollar
terms
and then divided that or divided market
cap by the annualized dormancy in dollar
terms
so taking the dormancy today you know
how much
how many dollars have been destroyed um
and then multiplying that out over 365
days
and so um what you see here is like we
have this almost full reset of dormancy
and
and that to me is showing like it's
partially affected by the fact that
we've had lower transfer volume because
by definition you're going to have lower
coinage strike because less coins are
trading but also to me
um it's showing that the noobs are slow
slowly getting
flushed out so like you can also look at
other things like the
raw average age of the coins being sold
um
we can even look at something called
spent output h bands and that looks at
basically like these different bands
based on um
the the age of the different uh entities
that hold the coins
so anyway so like i think it is
partially affected by lower transaction
volume but overall what this is showing
to me is that we kind of had this reset
of um
of of noobs in the market and we can we
can kind of build this this
foundation to move upwards because the
other times you've seen this were
actually in in major bear market bottoms
so in late 2018
uh 2015 and then also after the 2011
like initial
pump when bitcoin was uh you know first
brought out to the market so
got it and then sopra uh i know that
you're now looking at kind of this
adjusted version explain again what
sopra is and then the adjustments that
you're making
yeah sure sober is basically looking at
the profit taking
that coins hold on any day that's a good
way to think about it so
um ace opera is basically just adjusting
out the the one hour transaction so it's
kind of just filtering out the noise
you can also look at entity adjusted but
um i just
threw in a a soaper for this one but you
can you can look at bolts to kind of get
like
a more accurate picture and then you can
also look at long and short term
just for anybody who's interested but so
we had this break out above one which is
basically the threshold for like profit
or loss so if soap is trading above one
then um the market's trading in the
state of profit if it goes below it's
stating in a uh
a loss right so what you wanted to see
and we talked about this like two weeks
ago was for sober to perhaps break out
and then either
retest that one line on a price move
down and then kind of stabilize
and what we've actually seen this week
is we had that move down after we
initially got rejected off 42k
we actually did bounce off that one line
and that's a that's a bullish sign
because in bull markets you you see
soper that that one threshold
is kind of that mark for where uh where
bottoms are in corrections like if you
go back and look at it from like
uh december to march i mean almost every
time that sober dipped below one it was
like a perfect
uh perfect uh by the dip opportunity so
yeah i would like to now just see it
stabilize so now that we've got that
uh you know correction and price and
then bounce off one i now just kind of
like to see it stabilize above one
minor accumulation yeah
nothing really new here just uh mine are
still buying
and the miners they've been buying now
for weeks and just continuing to do that
no no sign of that slowing down it's
actually accelerating maybe a little bit
yeah slightly so like i threw in the
30-day change so you can look at their
actual
um like minor balance and just like oh
they sold today or they
you know bought some today but it gets
really noisy so like
this is the 30-day change so taking you
know today's uh
august 6th they're looking at august 6th
and then the difference between now and
july 6th
and that's that's the net change um and
so like
when you see there's a clear trend in
the net change you know that that's
showing like this broader trend right
because it's
it's going to take a larger trend to
affect this metric
just by definition so yeah i i think
this is a better way to look at it if
you're trying to follow what minors are
doing and yeah like you said this is
really showing uh
no sign of slowing down anytime soon got
it and the last one
is uh kind of you you presented a little
bit of a bear case so if you had to make
an argument against
what i think is your position as to
being bullish it's basically the
on-chain metrics around transaction
volume
yeah um this is kind of the one thing
that is a red flag to me is the fact
that we don't have more um
on-chain activity in terms of like when
you look at the mempool or just the the
number of transactions
um active addresses all these kinds of
things which i personally suspect are
kind of lagging indicators i think if
you start to see
um you know higher prices we start to
move towards like i don't know 45k
plus start moving towards 50k i think
you'll start to see uptick in this as
as you know volume picks up and people
become interested in again
um but yeah i think part of this has
just been the fact that we've been
ranging sideways for two or three months
and
i think of these as more lagging
indicators but it would you know this is
something you want to look for if we
start to move back up
obviously you're going to want to see um
you know this transaction activity
uh you know come back in as well but i
suspect it will but
you never know and it's just something
to keep an eye on got it and then the
last question the question that everyone
wants to know is while we are recording
this bitcoin just broke forty two
thousand dollars
uh and you previously had identified
that as a pretty big resistance
what do you think happens from here
fully knowing that you can't uh predict
the future
but what is uh what is your thought
process as to where we go
yeah so like we've just broken
horizontals uh
resistance at 42k and then we've also
broken
um this diagonal resistance line if you
draw
from like the the wake up in the 60ks
and then
we also retested that on the way down
when we uh came back to like
we retested 60k and hit it and then we
retested it a couple days ago anyway
so what i'm saying is we're we we just
broke out of
two major um trend lines right so both
diagonally and vert and uh horizontally
so
i think there's really nothing but hair
here until
about 48k but i think the uh the 200 a
moving average is
is going to give a bit of resistance and
that's right around 45k right now so
i'll be watching to see um you know we
might take a pause a little breather
there because
that's kind of a um a mark that a lot of
people in traditional finance look at
to see kind of like you know if an asset
is in like a bullish or bearish phase i
guess you could say
um so yeah i would be looking for that
but i'm targeting right now
49 50k and then seeing how we're gonna
kind of react there over there you know
i
think it'll perhaps play out over the
coming weeks got it
is there anything that uh people should
be watching out for as we kind of
break through that 42 and on the way up
other than uh prices
is there anything on chain that you'll
look for
um just in general like one thing was
was the volume right we were talking
about how we want to see that pick up
um that's one thing and then also the
long-term holder you don't want to see
them
dumping and you know just looking for
some kind of exit equity like we talked
about earlier um
sober stabilizing um and then in the
very short term just you can look at
futures
data just see how funding's looking um
you know look at
oi and just basic stuff like that for
like very short-term price movements
got it before i let you go everyone
loves when uh when will comes on people
even say will season uh what is uh
what was kind of your uh your final
words or
anything you want to share with folks uh
hang in there guys this thing's gonna
pop
i love it i love it uh all right well
thank you so much for doing this every
week you're doing fantastic work as
uh i've told people i'd say without you
here uh you by far
i think are leading the charge when it
comes to unchained metrics and uh
people are waking up to how important uh
a lot of that data is uh so folks can go
follow you on twitter or
subscribe to your newsletter where
should we send them on twitter or the
newsletter
yeah sure thanks for having me on man uh
i hope you guys get hyped again i know
this is a little
information uh heavy but i'll be
watching after i get off so you guys
better get the energy going again
uh you could find me on twitter at w
clementi iii
and then i have my newsletter is a btc
by wc3
sub stack dot com which is also my
twitter bio
killing it man thank you so much for
doing it we'll do it again next week
yes sir take it easy bob all right
sounds good hey guys
thanks so much for watching that clip of
the best business show make sure you
like and subscribe to the channel turn
on notifications so you know when we go
live every weekday
and then head to sofi.com so that you
can get an account
we can get after it